♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WELCOME
BACK TO "HANNITY."
WE CONTINUE FROM BEAUTIFUL
MIAMI.
NO INCOME TAX STATE FLORIDA.
WE ARE HERE WITH FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS,
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO WHO REALLY
WORKED HARD TO GET HERE DESPITE
WORKING LATE THIS AFTERNOON.
AND ALSO JOINING US NOW IS THE
DAUGHTER OF POLITICAL REFUGEES
FROM CUBA.
FLORIDA CONGRESSWOMAN, SHE'S
BEEN A FRIEND OF THE SHOW FOR A
LONG TIME AND A FRIEND OF MY
RADIO SHOW.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WELCOME TO LITTLE HAVANA.
THE HEART OF THE CUBAN
COMMUNITY.
WE REALLY WISH THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION THE SAME WAY THAT YOU
ARE SO WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR DOING THIS, PUTTING THE
SPOTLIGHT ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN CUBA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: YOU ARE VERY WELCOME.
AT THE TIME I MET ALL THREE OF
YOU, YOU WERE ALL PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
ONE QUESTION I HAVE, WHEN
JOE BIDEN, NOW THEY HAVE BEEN
FACILITATING THIS LAW BREAKING
OUT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
NOBODY GETS SENT BACK.
IT'S NOT EVEN CATCH AND RELEASE.
IT'S JUST RIGHT ON YOUR NAME,
RELEASE, AND WE WILL SHIP YOU
OFF TO ANOTHER STATE.
BUT YOU COME BY AND JOE IS
SAYING, NO, YOU WILL BE SENT
BACK.
AM I TO READ ANYTHING INTO THAT
OF?
>> WELCOME I THINK WHAT YOU READ
INTO IT IS THAT HE IS NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SCREAMING ON THE STREETS OF
HAVANA HERE YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
NOT SAYING DOWN WITH THE EMBARGO
OR WE WANT MORE VACCINES OR WE
WANT MORE FOOD.
NO, THEY ARE SAYING WE WANT
FREEDOM.
AND SOMETHING THAT MY COLLEAGUES
SAID HERE IS THAT MANY
DEMONSTRATIONS, YOU SEE THE
AMERICAN FLAG.
SO WHAT A COINCIDENCE THAT YOU
SEE THE AMERICAN FLAG FOR PEOPLE
WHO FEEL THE OPPRESSION OF
SOCIALISM.
WHILE IN THIS COUNTRY, SOME
PEOPLE ARE SPITTING ON IT.
SO THAT GOES TO SHOW YOU THAT
SOCIALISM, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
WERE YOU PUT IN FRONT OR BEHIND
IT, IT DOESN'T WORK.
AND WHAT I'M SAYING, SEAN, AND
ONCE AGAIN, WE THANK YOU.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO PAY ATTENTION TO US.
WE WANT EVERYBODY AGREE BIDEN
HAS BEEN MISSING IN ACTION?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU KNOW, I THINK BACK TO A TIME
IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN
RONALD REAGAN SUPPORTED THE
FREEDOM FIGHTERS IN NICARAGUA TO
FIGHT THEIR OWN BATTLE.
BUT THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR THE
FREEDOM MOVEMENT THERE.
BEYOND THE INTERNET, WE NEED
COMMUNICATION, SHOULD THAT BE ON
THE TABLE?
THE MIAMI MAYOR EVEN SAID VERY
AGGRESSIVELY, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS, SENATOR?
>> IT TOOK 24 HOURS FOR BIDEN TO
ISSUE HIS STATEMENT AND ANOTHER
72 HOURS.
THEN THEY DID A ZOOM CALL AND
CAME BACK WITH A THIRD
STATEMENT.
RIGHT NOW, WE CAN'T GET HIM TO
DO THE INTERNET, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GET HIM TO DO ANYTHING
ELSE?
IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE.
IF YOU WANT IF YOU MISSED
SENATOR RUBIO'S TWITTER
TIMELINE, IT'S NOW 8:30.
NOT A WORD FROM BIDEN.
NOW 1010.
I REALLY THINK SINGLE-HANDEDLY
YOU EMBARRASSED HIM IF YOU
FINALLY MAKE IT A STATEMENT.
>> IS JUST NOT A PRIORITY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, THERE IS
A STATEMENT OF HIS VOTING BASE
THAT ACTUALLY THINKS THE REGIME
IS GOOD, THAT ACTUALLY BRAGS
ABOUT THE REGIME.
PEOPLE OPENLY SAY IT.
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
FOUNDATION CITED.
MY OFFICE WILL HELP THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER IMMIGRATE TO CUBA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: GREAT POINT.
GOVERNOR, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WERE
NEARLY CRYING THAT I MET ON THE
WAY IN HERE.
THEY CAN'T COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR LOVED ONES AND THEIR
FRIENDS AND THEIR FAMILY.
AND THE INTERNET IS CRUCIAL.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND I THINK THERE IS GREAT
COWARDICE OF BIDEN.
THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO.
WHAT SHOULD THE DOCTRINE BE?
>> THIS IS THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE.
WE WANT TO HAVE NO INFLUENCE OF
PLACES LIKE RUSSIA AND CHINA.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU, IF BIDEN IS
MISSING IN ACTION, YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE CHINA AND RUSSIA IN SOME
OF THOSE HAVE EVEN MORE
INFLUENCE ON THE ISLAND OF CUBA
WITHOUT QUESTION.
I THINK YOU CAN WORK WITH
ORGANIZATION OF AMERICAN STATES.
I THINK THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO STAND
TOGETHER AND SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING OPPRESSED.
THEY SHOULD BE A NO-BRAINER
GIVEN THE HISTORY OF 62 YEARS OF
REPRESSION.
INSTEAD, YOU HAVE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION HAVING OUR OWN
COUNTRY BE CRITICIZED FOR
RACISM.
THEY ARE INVITING THAT.
THAT IS THEIR PRIORITY RATHER
THAN HELPING FOLKS WHO COULD
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
SO, IT'S BIZARRE.
>> Sean: IT'S VERY BIZARRE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
NOW WE TURN TO THE RADICAL
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS BLACK
LIVES MATTER, WHICH POINTED
SUPPORT FOR CUBA'S MURDEROUS
DICTATORSHIP.
A FULL REPORT.
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHERS,
BERNIE SANDERS, MICHAEL MOORE
BRAGGING ABOUT THEIR GREAT
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
ONE OF THE DUMBEST THINGS HE HAS
EVER SAID.
AOC AND OTHERS.
OUR OWN DAVID WEBB IS OUTSIDE
TONIGHT WITH US HERE IN MIAMI.
DAVID.
>> HEY SEAN, AND BY THE WAY, I
HAVE BEEN OUT HERE SINCE THIS
BEGAN.
FIRST WHEN THEY CAME OUT TO THE
STREETS ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON
INTO THE NIGHT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO END ANY
TIME AND IT SHOWN IT.
CUBA'S CRY FOR FREEDOM IS WHAT
WE ARE SEEN.
BUT HERE IN AMERICA, WE HAVE A
MARXIST BASED ORGANIZATION.
BLACK LIVES MATTER SAYS THEY
CARE ABOUT BLACK LIVES.
WHAT ABOUT CUBANS.
THEY DON'T BECAUSE COMMUNISM
DOESN'T KNOW COLOR.
ADD MARXISTS LIKE BLACK LIVES
MATTER HAVE COME OUT OUTWARDLY
AGAINST THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE A FRAUD.
IT'S A GRIP.
THEY ARE A DANGEROUS FRAUD AND
GRIP.
I WENT OUT TO CALLE OCHO AND
SPOKE TO SO MANY PEOPLE,
GRANDSONS, GRANDDAUGHTERS.
I ALSO SPOKE TO PEOPLE WHO HAD
SURVIVED PRISON IN CUBA.
AND BELIEVE ME, THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
BUT THEY DO UNDERSTAND
COMMUNISM.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW ANYONE
IN THIS COUNTRY, ANYONE
SUPPORTED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA CAN
SUPPORT COMMUNISM.
WE HAVE HAD A CONGRESS --
I SPOKE TO THIS ONE YOUNG WOMAN.
JUST WATCH THIS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY, NOT ONLY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
NOW THEY SAY THEY ARE FOR BLACK
LIVES.
THEY SAY THEY SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE.
AND YET THEY JUST CAME OUT IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENT IN CUBA.
WHAT YOU SAY TO BLACK LIVES
MATTER CUSTOMER >> I BELIEVE
THAT IF YOU FIGHT FOR INJUSTICE
AGAINST A GROUP OF PEOPLE, IT'S
INJUSTICE.
HOW CAN YOU ALLOW OR SUPPORT
INJUSTICE AGAINST A GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE OPPRESSED?
IF THEY ARE FIGHTING AGAINST
OPPRESSION OF COLORED PEOPLE,
GUESS WHAT, THERE ARE COLORED
PEOPLE IN CUBA TOO.
WHAT ABOUT THEIR LAST?
TO THEIR LIVES NOT MATTER?
>> SHE SAID IT WELL, SEAN.
THE WORLD SHOULD BE LISTENING.
MULTIMILLIONAIRE COMMUNIST
SUPPORTING THE CUBAN REGIME.
BACK TO YOU, SEAN.
FROM OUTSIDE CAFE VERSAILLES.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, DAVID,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US NOW IS
A CUBAN BORN DEMOCRACY ACTIVIST,
SHE IS WITH US AS WE ALSO
CONTINUE WITH SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO, GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I WILL TELL YOU WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT I HAVE TALKED TO OUT
THERE, I FIND IT INSPIRING.
YOU KNOW, WE TAKE THINGS FOR
GRANTED, RIGHT?
WE PROBABLY SHOULD ALL WAKE UP
EVERY DAY BEFORE OUR FEET HIT
THE GROUND.
THE REST OF THE WORLD DOESN'T
LIVE FREE.
WHEN I READ THE STATISTICS ABOUT
THE POVERTY, WIDESPREAD, IT IS
SO PREVENTABLE.
AND YET, THE SUPPRESSION GOES
ON, AND MURDER, AND DEATH, AND
NO FREEDOM.
>> THAT, IN ADDITION TO THAT,
THERE IS A HUGE --
VERY OPPRESSIVE DICTATE TO
ORIOLE, TOTALITARIAN
DICTATORSHIP AS THE ONE THAT WE
HAVE IN CUBA.
HAPPINESS, LIBERTY.
THE PEOPLE IN CUBA CANNOT EVEN
FIND.
>> Sean: I REALLY BELIEVE, AND
I DISCUSSED THIS EARLIER.
CAN YOU IMAGINE CUBA FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW, IF THIS WAS A
SUCCESSFUL FREEDOM AND LIBERTY
MOVEMENT, COULD YOU IMAGINE THE
INVESTMENT, FIRST OF ALL, WHAT
BEAUTIFUL GEOGRAPHY.
WHAT INCREDIBLE RESORTS WILL BE
FILLED TO WHAT MONEY AND
INVESTMENT WOULD GO INTO THE
COASTAL TOWNS, THE JOBS CREATED,
THE WEALTH CREATED.
NO, PEOPLE FINALLY NOW
PROSPERING.
THEY WOULD HAVE THEIR FIRST
CHANCE.
>> THE CUBAN PEOPLE ALSO IMAGINE
THAT.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR
FREEDOM.
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WE NEED
TO PRODUCE FOOD, BUILDINGS, HAD
TO BE PROSPEROUS AND BEAUTIFUL
COUNTRY THAT ACTUALLY COULD BE
AN EXAMPLE IN THE WORLD.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUICK QUESTION.
SHOW OF HANDS OR CLAP, MAYBE
CLAP.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HERE HAVE LOVED
ONES, FRIENDS, NEIGHBORS THAT
YOU SEND MONEY TO BECAUSE YOU
KNOW HOW BADLY THEY ARE
SUFFERING?
A LOT OF PEOPLE HELP PEOPLE OUT
IN CUBA THAT ARE IN CUBA NOW
THAT YOU ARE HELPING?
YOU ARE ALL RAISING YOUR HAND.
THEY CAN'T SEE THEM ALL.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT THEY ARE HELPING A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE PRETTY DESPERATE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK.
THIS IS GOING TO BE FUN.
WE ARE GOING TO GO OUTSIDE.
A LOT OF DEMONSTRATORS.
THEY HAVE BEEN OUTSIDE FROM DAY
ONE HAS THIS LIBERTY MOVEMENT
HAS STARTED, SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST THE EVILS OF COMMUNISM
IN CUBA.
THEY WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK